a towering plume of smoke and ash
filled the sky over saint vincent as la
soufriere
volcano continued to shake the caribbean
island
with violent explosions the cloud rose
15 kilometers into the sky and was
visible from space
the situation is that we're currently
experiencing
a very intense ash fall throughout most
of
mainland vincent we've been experiencing
this since
late yesterday the explosive portion of
of the eruption began yesterday morning
and as we
went into the night last night we had uh
the intensity
and and the amount of ash increased
quite considerably
ash covered houses roads and cars
and the smell of sulfur hung in the air
about sixteen
thousand people have been evacuated from
the so-called red zone
surrounding the volcano this morning
some people fled by coast guard vessels
to safer areas
several cruise ships were also assisting
in the evacuation effort
until recently la soufriere had been
quiet
for decades but in 1902 a severe
eruption
resulted in the deaths of at least a
thousand people
there now some 78 emergency shelters
that are active at this point in time
and the last figure we have is 3000
individuals
living in these shelters at this point
in time
there have been no reports of injuries
or deaths in the latest eruption
but damage to crops and farms is
expected to be severe ash from la
supriere
fell as far away as barbados nearly 200
kilometers from saint vincent
countries including antigua cuba guyana
venezuela and the united states
are sending aid to the island nation
home
to 100 000 people scientists
warned that the eruption could continue
for days
or even weeks rob reynolds al jazeera